For a long time I understood nihilism
very well.
I could,
I could understand its rationale
associated with the tragedy of life
associating with suffering and evil
associated with the observation of
finitude and the arbitrary and unjust
nature of the world,
but the more I've thought about it,
the less I've come to believe that
there's any excuse for it whatsoever,
and I think the reason for that is that
it forestalls effort.
It forestalls the ability to discover
for yourself maybe there's no reason to
be so God damn hopeless except that it's
easier to be useless now,
and I'm not.
Believe me,
I'm not making that case.
I'm not saying that that's what's be
setting people who are clinically
depressed,
for example.
That's not my point.
Clinical depression is a terrible thing.
There's lots of reasons to be rendered
to be,
to be tossed into a catastrophic
condition.
That isn't what I mean.
I mean that kind of cynical,
arrogant,
rational,
hyper-intelligent nihilism that throws
the world away as if it's of little use
before it's been properly engaged with
better to engage with it and see what
happens and better to make the
assumption that if the world isn't
returning to you,
what it is that you need,
then either you're not doing it right or
you've conceptualized what you need
badly.
Why not at least open yourself up to
that possibility,
right?
Because you could be wrong.
Hopefully if you're suffering,
this is a great thing to know.
you're wrong,
because if you're suffering and you're
right,
then there's nowhere to go,
so it's very useful to find out whatever
errors you might be committing.
Another thing that's really interesting
about the Jews in the Old Testament,
it's a remarkable thing.
Every single time they get flattened by
God,
it's always their fault.
They never say,
the world that God created was corrupt
and God is evil.
They never say that no matter what
happens,
right,
no matter what catastrophe occurs,
when they have every reason to at least
put that hypothesis forward,
they don't.
They say,
we aired,
we walked off the path,
it's our fault,
and that's hard,
you know,
because it puts all the weight of human
catastrophe on the human being.
That's very hard,
but the upside is
it gives you the control.
It opens up the door that it opens up
the possibility that you could be the
person that could set it right.
If you would just let go of what's in
your way,
whatever that is.